[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with Kevin Schofield and Annabelle denim
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
well tomorrow's Metro has the headline
senseless violence reporting police
condemn drive-by gun Maniacs Rampage at
funeral
teacher strikes make the front of
tomorrow's eye which warns students face
a return to online lessons
the express leads with the UK's growing
housing crisis its headline Countryside
Under Siege in rush for homes
whereas the times looks at the NHS
crisis with the headline two in three
voters I think NHS offers bad service
the Ft focuses its attention on a
meeting tomorrow in Switzerland where
global leaders will discuss what it
calls a new era of economic uncertainty
and higher interest rates its headline
States companies face billions in write
Downs as Davos confronts a souring
economy
New Hope killer will not go free reads
the front of tomorrow's mirror which is
dedicated to the mother of murdered
toddler James Bulger who has revealed
one of his Killers may never be freed
under a planned parole overhaul
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Kevin Schofield and Annabelle Denham
welcome to you both let's start by
having a look at the front page of the
eye and this is the potential strike by
teachers which might ensue children in
England and ways base return to online
lessons for the first time since
lockdown and this is under government's
contingency plans Annabelle take us into
this story
sure yeah so this is on the cover of the
eye it's the news that teaching unions
are going to be announcing their ballot
result uh today the um Neu is claiming
that it's met the threshold uh for a
strike so you know it's not just a
question of what this means the course
of teaching unions but what it means for
pupils and the knock-on effect that it's
going to have on the economy as parents
are potentially not able to work because
they're at home supporting their kids
with a home schooling you know I think
it's going to be really interesting to
see how people respond to this there
seems to have been a lot of public
Sympathy for the nurses say going on
strike I would
um suggest that perhaps public support
for rail workers is perhaps beginning to
wane slightly and it'll be interesting
to see how much people throw their
weight behind the teaching unions
because of what school children went
through during the coronavirus pandemic
now the positive of course is that
because of the pandemic schools are able
to deal with a remote learn learning
perhaps a lot better than they were
prior to 2020 but on the other hand
children missed a huge amount of
schooling many still won't have caught
up there's a real risk for the
government this is going to further sour
talks with other unions or encourage
other unions to themselves ballot their
members I think we can see it as an
escalation with you know many of those
unions going on strike uh going on
strike more frequently and like I said
you know I think that the real concern
for me at least is is that the effects
of the pandemic still linger for many uh
school children tens of thousands of
children have gone missing from school
roles and have yet to reappear we know
that the containment Gap widened between
what children from more privileged
backgrounds and children from
underprivileged backgrounds during the
pandemic this could perhaps be further
exacerbated by teaching strikes so look
you know let's see what what happens
tomorrow but I really hope that the
government and the teaching unions are
able to come to some sort of agreement
and so that children aren't stuck back
at home in front of their computer
screens remote learning again yes they
have been particularly hard done by
through the the pandemic children at
school and also students at universities
but Kevin I wonder whether you think
there will be public sympathy if the
teachers do decide to come out
I think maybe initially uh there will be
but yeah I think um parents will
remember and are still scarred about a
thing from the experience of Home
Learning um for months at a time during
uh lockdown so maybe any sympathy me
real quick uh quickly vanish that that
being said I'm not entirely sure how
this um online uh learning contingency
plan is going to work because I mean if
if most teachers are going to be on
strike then who's going to be given
these lessons
um even if they're online you know so
I'm not entirely sure how it will work I
mean obviously the whole point of
industrial action is to cause disruption
and make things difficult for people uh
in the hope that that will then bring
the employers back to the table to
improve the pay deal but you know these
things are always a bit of a gamble as
far as changing these are concerned but
we are led to believe that the National
Education Union
um will announce tomorrow that their
members have voted four-strike action
they've met the required threshold and
that um strike dates will then be
announced and yeah it will cause huge
disruption because you're looking at
tens of thousands of teachers either on
picket lines or staying at home which
means kids not being able to be taught
and having to stay at home themselves
and obviously parents then being left
without either paying for extra child
care or having to work from home or take
days off to look after their kids so
yeah it is a real mess and it's just
another sign that this winter of
discontent is going on
yes and uh Annabelle it seems as if the
government is sort of firefighting now
to kind of mitigate any effects of any
potential strike they're planning to
issue guidance tomorrow calling for
vulnerable children to be allowed into
class during any walkout
yes that's right and as Kevin says it's
hard to see exactly how this is going to
work if uh teachers are themselves uh
going on strike how are they going to
ensure that there's provision now for
the more of vulnerable children and how
are they how are the children who are at
home supposedly learning uh going to
have any interaction with their teachers
during that period it's hard to see at
the moment how how this is actually
going to work now of course we're not at
that point yet there will be discussions
uh between uh government ministers and
the teaching unions both sides I imagine
will be Keen to come to some some sort
of agreement because both really depend
on on public opinion having that on
their side and that they seem they seem
not to be very forthcoming in those
negotiations that may go against them so
let's see what kind of provision the
schools are going to be willing to put
in place especially for those vulnerable
children but also for children who are
at home trying to uh remote learn and
and let's see how those conversations go
in the future but certainly it's just
adding to that that date for the
government which as you say is fighting
on so many fronts at the moment take us
to the express cabin and we read that uh
the countryside is under siege because
of a housing crisis
yeah so the express obviously it has an
older leadership so I think this story
is certainly targeted at the end they
may have concerns about
um Greenfield sites in their area
um being taken over for housing
development but but the bottom line is
in this country we don't build enough
houses and that's part of the reason why
house prices are as high as they are and
by young people these days struggle to
get on the housing ladder
um and now the government have this
target of 300 000 homes a year they've
never come anywhere close to hitting it
and they're not going to do it this year
either uh Russia students come under a
lot of pressure as well from
conservative MPS to to drop that Target
um because they obviously come under
pressure from their constituents who
don't want housing developments near
whoever they live so it's an ongoing
tension really between the need for the
government
um to create questions who are buying
new houses can be built to meet the
demand that there is out there but it
comes up against uh local campaign
groups as the front page of the express
is saying who complain about these
um uh developments going on in their
areas so you know it's a very difficult
problem it's one that is bedeviled
um governments of all political
Persuasions for years and clearly it
doesn't look like we're any closer to
reaching a solution no well more than
400 000 homes have planning permission
on Greenfield though saying not in my
backyard do they have a point Annabelle
well I mean you can you can see why this
is a real dilemma for the conservative
party on the one hand it has its MPS who
are representing their constituents uh
in the shires who don't want to see 400
000 homes
um built on you know what is presented
and painted as very beautiful uh bucolic
uh Greenbelt Land which actually often
is uh sort of farming land which is a
lot less attractive than perhaps people
have believed uh led to believe and on
the other hand of course it has younger
voters who are increasingly turning away
from the conservative party and what
we're seeing is the age of which people
do start to vote conservative is rising
and rising and the conservative party
are going to need to find ways of of
attracting those voters and you know
looking at this and and its failure to
liberalize planning that really just
feeds into this in generational uh
conflict it's engineering national uh
unfairness in the general sense of
disillusionment that I think a lot of
young people have with the conservative
party at the moment that is at some
point going to have to address so I
think this failure to reform planning
this failure to build housing which of
course was exacerbated
um last month by the uh Villas uh
Amendment which is leading to the
government scrapping house building
targets it's just going to you know
exacerbate that further but it's a real
so short-term
um View and I think the government is
going to need to take a longer term view
if it has any hope of of winning in 2020
for 2025 which at the moment is looking
very very remote indeed Kevin take us to
the financial times and explain how it
is that uh Wishy sunak is about to hit
the Constitutional nuclear option
yeah I mean this is uh a really big
story brewing and I think it's going to
come to our head this week possibly even
as soon as tomorrow
um basically uh the Scottish Parliament
uh just for Christmas passed the law and
reforming gender uh recognition laws
basically making it easier
um for Trans people to
um change their gender now
um under the terms of the Scotland act
uh Westminster can
um block bills passed at Scotland from
becoming law now this has never happened
before in almost 25 years of the
Scottish parliament's existence
obviously it is the nuclear option as
the financial time says but all the
indications are that this week the
government will in fact do that they say
this bill which is passed in Scotland
and will cut across the um uh equality
act South of the Border so and basically
say that you can't have that law because
it impinges on laws and in the rest of
the UK and it's going to cause a huge uh
constitutional Studios as we would say
in Scotland it's going to be a huge
route the s p are going to turn around
and say well this is Westminster once
again and telling Boston Scotland that
I'm not letting Scotland's Parliament do
what it wants and it's going to be a
huge political headache for Chris sunach
the other thing that makes it um quite
controversial as well is that this bill
in Scotland it's been quite
controversial north of the Border as
well including among a lot of SNP
politicians so the question is do they
support the UK government in blocking it
or do they back their leader in saying
that this is at an outrage and an attack
on the Scottish Parliament itself so
yeah you can see why it has all the
ingredients for a pretty big um
constitutional row yeah it's just very
quickly Annabelle before we go to the
break it does seem as though the prime
minister is up for this fight
well I look I mean it does at the moment
I'll believe it when I see it Jillian um
there's a big question of course as to
why he's blocking if he's blocking it
because he thinks that it will have
significant impacts on the rest of the
UK
um that that seems entirely reasonable
and let's not forget that there's
already
um you know real complications about how
uh the gender recognition act interacts
with um the equalities act
um you know already and this is it's
just really exacerbating that
um you know I just hope they're not
blocking it um to find a way to try and
take a stand against the SMP
um but you know fundamentally the
Devolution system uh is broken I think
this is is really underscoring that okay
I just don't know if Richard will go
press ahead and actually block it I'll
do it when I see it Annabelle we must
leave it there for the moment Annabelle
and Kevin thank you very much we're
going to take a break and uh coming up
we'll take a look at the Daily Telegraph
which has this headline police empowered
to act on protest palm oil you stay with
us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Kevin Schofield
the political editor of healthpost UK
and Annabelle Denham the director of
communications at The Institute of
economic Affairs welcome back to both of
you let's have a look at the front page
of the metro and this is this awful
drive-by shooting that we've been
reporting on uh very close to Houston
Station in London senseless violence is
the headline Kevin
yeah and it's a pretty Stark headline
it's an absolutely Dreadful story
um shocked entire country I think and I
think it just shows the worrying rise
and gun crime obviously we've seen
recent incidents and on on merseyside as
well and I think it just adds to the
sense in the country that um crime is
actually starting to get out of control
I mean it's a type of incident that you
know not so long ago you would never
expect to see
um on the UK streets and for that to
happen right in the center of London on
a Saturday afternoon is um is pretty
shocking and obviously the police are
now desperately trying to find the
gunman responsible for what is a
horrific
a rough a incident and hopefully uh the
public will help them in that endeavor
yes and they are appealing for people to
to come forward witnesses to come
forward but Annabelle made all the worse
by the fact that people were attending
at a funeral
yes that's absolutely right they're
attending a Requiem Mass memorial
service for this mother and daughter who
themselves tragically died within I
think about three weeks of one another
you know its census really does seem to
sum it up and some you know it's just
extraordinary
um situation extraordinary uh event you
know this fact that this shotgun the
choice of weapon being a shotgun so you
have this culture the cartridge that is
full of pellets that manage to injure
six people you have a seven-year-old
girl who is in a stable but
life-threatening uh condition
um this happening as Kevin says you know
in daylight you know close to Houston
Station this is just just not the sort
of thing really that you expect to
happen
um here in the UK and I think it has it
has shot people up and down the country
it's just just an awful awful thing to
have happened indeed it is to the Daily
Telegraph Kevin and tell us about this
change to be made to the public order
bill which would give police powers to
crack down on slow walking protest
yeah so this is the public order bill
um currently going through Parliament
the government is going to introduce an
amendment tomorrow basically clarifying
the law and giving the police greater
powers to crack down on protests
including these slow walking protests
now we had them quite a few of them last
year environmental activists just
stopped oil
um Extinction Rebellion
um you know as part of their tactics was
to walk through busy uh town and City
centers we saw in the center of of
London close to Westminster I saw one
one day of just walking slowly and the
police at the moment weren't sure
whether the powers that they have and
give them the right to intervene it
didn't whether it was classified as
serious disruption or not so this new
Amendment where it's a pass would allow
them to intervene uh more quickly and
the government certainly hopes and
bringing in to these types of protests
because there's no doubt as indeed as
the whole point of the process they
cause massive disruption huge
frustration for motorists uh trying to
get about their business and um the
government obviously see this as a as a
political problem as well uh because
ultimately people blame the government
for things like this and then they want
the police now to have the powers that
they think are necessary in order to
intervene so it'll be interesting to see
uh how quickly they can get this onto
the statue group and whether in fact
actually has an impact on whether the
protesters just change their tactics to
try and keep one step ahead of the um of
of law enforcement